a problematic area of human capital in
high tech which we we put a lot of
emphasis you know from the ceo level in
the authority
and all of us are really involved and
how do we um break the mold here you
know how do we how do we bring
more good people to the industry the
industry is striving you know we have to
jump from
to 15
in nothing in in
really relatively no time welcome to 20
minute leaders just sit back relax and
learn from the leaders of today it's a
journey each one is different unique
inspiring let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders let's talk about innovation and
government put together meet karina
rubinstein director of business
development startup division israel
innovation authority karina is a senior
director of business development at the
israel innovation authority and has a
vast experience in helping israeli
startups and companies build innovation
strategies and their global presence
karina rubinstein welcome to 20 minute
leaders from the israel innovation
authority how are you
i'm fine michael thank you so much for
this wonderful opportunity i'm really
happy no no thank you so much both for
you being here but also for the great
work that you're doing because you know
i get to speak with a lot of
entrepreneurs and investors a lot from
israel as well on this show being
israeli myself and and finally i get to
understand you know there's a larger
umbrella to everything that we're doing
here is something called the startup
nation this high-tech ecosystem which we
are all so happy to be a part of and
then there's the israel innovation
authority which is this this body
that you will tell me in a second a
little bit more about what it does but
essentially you know i can tell you from
the entrepreneur perspective it's the
sense of there's this body in israel
that that is here to support the
ecosystem and and help israel both grow
as an ecosystem but help also individual
startups succeed on their own and so
very excited to have you here running
business development for the
organization karina tell me a little bit
about yourself and
how do you perceive your role within
this ecosystem
well i joined the authority four years
ago so i i come from the industry
actually i was like
more than 20 years doing business
development
for startups
you know basically for startups i'm a
startup person so
you know we have a joint thing
um
and i was actually helping startups in
the in the uh in the stage that they
were you know starting to do something
and there was nothing there really i
assume you know the situation the stage
and we were you know
trying to build platforms uh in
international markets for these startups
uh
uh gaining market traction and all of
that uh so
actually through my years um
the the experience were piling up and um
and now what i bring to the table in the
uh authority is actually uh you know a
really vast experience or in all kinds
of verticals so i moved
technologically you know you you bring
your skill sets at the end of the day
what you do in in trying to connect and
trying to
broaden the opportunities or seize the
opportunities you know you can look at
it from various angles but at the end of
the day this is what you bring it
doesn't really matter if you move from a
medical device to media
to uptech to
you know digital health
you know there is a span of it but in
the end of the day that's what i uh i
was doing and actually all of that i
brought to the um authorities so
basically someone told me this morning
you know you are like the disneyland of
opportunities in the authority because
really
and i think myself and the team that i'm
part of um we all look at them how do we
create more impact how do we help the
industry
you know how do we translate your needs
into something practical that we can
be
of help there you know
have good solutions
so that's you know in a nutshell
israel innovation authority as a body
you know we're combining the words
authority innovation and israel three
things that you know each of them alone
could be
you know in so many different things
what happens when you put these three
words together what does it mean the
israel innovation authority as a body
yeah
daily struggling but yeah but you know
the idea was there
five years ago we were basically back
then the
chief scientist in the
ministry of economy for years and that
was an establishment by itself you know
we helped quite a lot the the idea that
the government of israel is committed to
investment in innovation over the years
you know it started back then i think in
the 70s or so and then
went through establishing the vc
industry you were talking back you know
before about yourself and your
involvement in the venture capital there
was nothing here in the beginning of the
90s so the the government of israel
actually created this kind of an
infrastructure for
then on startups to be created you know
back then there are several big
you know companies like high tech
companies and nothing other than that
so what is this common around the world
to have governments creating unique
positions within the government to
support a startup innovative ecosystem
i think it's part of the dna here you
know we had delegations before the
corona i think 400 people per week
coming from around the world to see what
what is it all about how does how does
this model working
so they are trying to duplicate it but
then at the end of the day you need the
dna you need a culture mindset you know
in a sense so
it all combines together at the end of
the day but i think we are now trying
past you know fast forward five years
that we are operating as a as an
independent authority we are trying to
to do extensively
much much more
than what we uh
you know
been able to do as a government ministry
so
our our um operation is much wider today
we have a
you know relatively uh big budget like
something like half a billion dollars a
year
and all of that goes to support the
industry all of that if we if we were
struggling now at the end of the of this
you know 21 year
we were struggling
to move the last penny to the industry
at the the last day so really we we're
trying our best to do you know more and
more each year
um
looking at what we are doing it's uh
it's enormous really it's enormous it's
a really large scale
and and i have a quite a few portfolio
companies that i'm personally involved
with who've been receiving grants from
the israel innovation authority and and
they are go from medical technology all
the way to
deep technology looking at you know
investigating neural networks and i and
i keep thinking to myself like wow what
is this crazy body that is you know
matching you know our investments and is
basically doubling the investment around
that some of these companies in the
preceding city stages are getting what
is the model here are you a venture
capitalist are you an advisor you know
how what what so what is the day-to-day
like of the israel innovation authority
well that's a good question but we you
know i can say that we are a major
investor in the industry
non-equity though you know
non-equity right yeah non-dilutive that
has to be said
but we do look at the you know unlike
venture capitalists or or
investors uh be whoever they are
we are
supporting from applied research in the
academia or commercializing ip from the
academia and then singular entrepreneurs
you know with only an idea in their head
early-stage startups companies that
growth manufacturing companies the human
capital in high tech so we're looking at
the holistically how do we create a
stronger ecosystem here in israel
it's not only how do we support startups
per se
ins and you know in a specific area
because we are agnostic to the vertical
that you are as long as you are
innovative and disruptive and that's
what we're looking at primarily i mean
we we nowadays trying to focus our
you know our resources in areas where
the private market is not there so i
think our impact is where there's the
scarcity of of private market investors
wouldn't go
so much into you know i was the the your
a previous call that i have before you
someone from the water technology area
and he was saying there's not enough
investment uh here foreign investors are
not here are not president or lower
israel is known in the world for their
water technologies you know for its
water technologies so
we are the only i mean we are with there
with you know all kinds of other ones
but majority of the of the support
coming is coming from us to this these
kinds of areas and there are really
highly important now looking at the
climate you know
change and all of that uh
it's really important to have these
kinds of cutting-edge technologies uh in
israel so we're looking at the
you know where it's it's training to be
highly risky
and
and we are there
we are there
and of course wherever we can spread the
um infrastructures
that you know vcs wouldn't wouldn't
invest in infrastructure for you
companies to work on so you know
whatever relates to
incubators
innovation labs
other kinds of uh
research institutes that we can provide
the meaning for their infrastructures
for you companies to work for with you
know so
the the these are the areas that our
budget is really you know focused in the
in the last years more and more now the
israel innovation authority is a
governmental body right
right
startups are used to dealing with the
government in not not necessarily the
same
optimistic grant-like manner that they
might be interacting with israel
innovation authority not just in terms
of you know the relationship often
between government and the businesses of
the country but but also in terms of you
know the dialogue and the forms that you
have to fill out and the long processes
what how do you gauge through mitigating
that difference and that is the you know
the dissonance between the governmental
side the innovation side and the the
entire ecosystem as a whole
i think you know part of the reason that
people like myself are in the authority
is for us to be more proactive and more
reachable for the industry
and i think we are trying to translate
it into you know
into informal relationship on a daily
basis i'm really communicated with
whoever on my what's up all the time all
the day in in un
usual hours as well
and and and and this is uh why i'm here
i'm i'm here to do that exactly i think
um 90
of the people in the authority now
nowadays we are like now i think around
140 people
90 of us are coming from the industry
you know wow so
so you're not looking at the government
organization as as it is you know used
to be perceived
years back um without you know uh
offending any anyone you know in the in
the other ministries all of my
colleagues really are fine people trying
to do whatever they can to push forward
but i do think that we understand the
complexities and we're trying to do
different differently so we are
struggling ourselves sometimes with
things that are you know
the the system is working in a different
way and
you know
we're trying to push walls we succeed
most of the time i have to say
karina what is your day-to-day like look
at the israel innovation authority
running their business development what
what is your day-to-day life look
i think well
i would say around 80 of it is talking
with the industry meeting with the
industry trying to solve whatever i can
trying to
facilitate most of the time facilitate
whatever i can
uh try trying to to to you know to have
my two cents uh
contributing
in things that are not related
specifically to our you know funding
tools per se
i i you know i
i bring whatever i can
to to help the industry so this is more
or less you know i think
a generic
day of mine but other than that we're
trying to translate whatever we hear
into workable
channels or workable tools so this is
another like
20 30 percent
or more and so
spending 80 percent talking to the
industry and coming from the industry
where are we at right now we've just
opened 2022 israel is in an incredible
boom with a scale-up nation not just a
startup nation and i i feel the energy
and i feel the progression that we're
making on a daily basis i'm seeing
entrepreneurs that are more mature and
are thinking bigger and with greater
visions than what i believe we have
we've had before as an ecosystem
how do you perceive where we're at now
and where do you think we're headed in
the next few years
well you know first of all we see a
trend of uh um
more experienced entrepreneurs coming
back like you know like what you
described before uh to israel opening
new companies and uh and so the trend of
uh
someone asked me a few days ago what is
this the exit strategy as i was saying
uh you know maybe not not an exit
strategy that will be the strategy
in a sense but building uh establishing
a uh uh companies here um established
companies you know and this is what a
trend that we would like to strengthen
more more and more i think by that we
can really bring
build a strong industry at the end of
the day
and that's where we're heading to and i
think
the other pain
that we see is the
is the problematic area of human capital
in high tech which we we put a lot of
emphasis you know from the ceo level in
the authority
and all of us are really involved and
how do we
break the mold here you know how do we
how do we bring
more good people to the industry the
industry is striving you know we have to
jump from
to 15
in nothing in in
really relatively no time
and uh and not in a generic way so how
do we bring more people to the industry
more people by the way not only
you know programmers or so which is
really you know really common and that's
another problem data science and all of
that
but what we see is there's a really
strong trend of people like coming from
you know biz dev
sales and marketing
you know
um
these kinds of areas myself you know
looking back uh you know in my
own personal experience and nobody no
one taught that back then
there were really a few companies that
were hiring people in israel to do so
usually we were dependent on the us for
that
but now what you see is a different kind
of a trend and i think that couples with
the law you know with people making
aliyah from all around the world and
bringing on uh you know
a very good knowledge in foreign
languages and the culture mind and so on
they know how to move around with these
skill sets and that is very good for the
industry so beyond doing only r d here
that is a very good formula to form here
you know a full full companies or
complete companies and that's
what i think this is these are two of
the things that are really
uh you know uh
moving around here in the authority very
much we putting a lot of emphasis on
that i would say on the other way on the
other hand
you know millennials have their own
mindset and
and it's a good thing because they're
looking at how do
they create impact
not only do you know the job
and i think moving
these uh people from
only writing a code to writing a code
with an impact
is also a trend that we see and we would
like to strengthen it so i i'm talking
with a lot of entrepreneurs
and people that only you know
you know
finish the army uh
finish the university or whatever
they're looking at how to move on to
areas that are you know dealing with the
foodtech
climatetech um you know these kinds of
area and uh and health and i think it's
really important to encourage them to
give them to facilitate the um
that for them
what is top of mind for you now so when
you're going to sleep tonight what is
keeping you up or what is sort of your
top priority as you see it in in your
role today
how do we tend more for the periphery of
israel of israel how do we create more
high tech there
uh
not by the way just by shortening the
time to uh you know traveling time
between the periphery to the center of
israel necessarily but to how do we
create ecosystems here it's really uh
it's really something of you know it's
part of my passion
really really i have a personal
involvement in that and how do we create
more um
how to bring more uh
under represented uh populations uh in
high tech to the high tech so we do a
lot of activity this year uh
around
arabs
entrepreneurs arabs in high tech
and so on women we would like to see
more women entrepreneur
and and also the heretic population
so we we do a lot of activities around
that and we are not you know we haven't
succeeded in moving moving the needles
so much it's it's sadly i'm saying that
it's uh it's something that we um
we put a lot of thinking into so you
know these two
subjects more or less revolving around
my mind
thank you so much for
your time and not just here but in the
israel innovation authority and and i'm
astounded by the numbers that you shared
with me before
half a billion dollars of budget to
contribute to the ecosystem and now it's
starting to make sense why i'm seeing
all these incredible companies that are
getting these non-dilutive grants from
the israel innovation authorities so and
what's also also really amazing to me
you know you're saying that 90
of the people working in the authority
are actually from the industry and i
think this is the you know exactly the
the the idea behind why why you're able
to forge the gap from the government to
innovation and under the umbrella of an
ecosystem is by also bringing the
ecosystem into the government and now i
can understand it much better so thank
you very much for your time and stay
safe and stay healthy
thank you so much michael
[Music]